*musique frénétique*
*sons jeux vidéo*
*bruit d'impact*
Ça va monsieur?
Merci beaucoup!
Enfoiré!
Comment je peux vous remercier?
Ah ça?
Ah oui oui oui,
non mais... vous savez...
Un grand pouvoir implique
de grandes responsabilités.
Ça me dit quelque chose ça.
Je peux vous payer un verre?
Ah ben ouais carrément!
En plus... il suffit juste
que je prévienne ma m-
Mon coloc et c'est bon quoi.
Ok.
Du coup on le laisse là lui?
T'es sûr que t'en veux pas?
Non merci.
Et alors comme ça tu fais de l'UFC?
Ouais voilà c'est ça ouais.
Mais l'UFC c'est une ligue,
Le sport c'est pas du free fight?
Ah ouais...
Nan parce que moi je fais plus
des combats clandestins quoi.
C'est pas... c'était pour l'idée quoi.
Parce que moi j'aime...
C'est pour les mecs qui adore la bagarre,
les *pchhhh*.
Les trucs comme ça tu vois.
Tu sais que...
J'aimerais vraiment vraiment voir ça.
Ah ouais?
Ah ouais direct.
Euh...
Alors...
Nan, on va faire...
on va plus faire...
Comme si je te prenais par surprise quoi.
Admettons si je te tiens comme ça.
On est d'accord que là tu peux rien faire ?
*bruit d'impact*
Oh je t'ai fait mal?
Nan nan c'est bon.
C'est exactement ce
que je voulais te montrer.
T'as de bons réflexes.
Je saigne?
*musique romantique*
Je sais exactement ce qu'il te faut.
Ah ouais?
Viens avec moi.
Euh qu'est ce qu'on fait là?
J'avais envie de te faire plaisir.
C'est lui?
Oui.
C'est moi quoi?
Ok viens avec moi!
Nan mais c'est moi quoi là?
*musique dubstep*
Allé viens dépêche toi!
Poussez vous!
Ça va être bientôt à toi!
Ah ben c'est à toi.
Nan attendez!
Attendez c'est un malentendu là !
Nan nan nan mais parce que en fait
moi j'ai dit que je savais boxais,
mais en vérité je sais pas du tout boxer.
Je suis une baltringue moi!
Nan attendez, non laissez moi!
En réalité c'est un pot de fleur qui lui ai...
tombé dessus...
Allé Guilain, allé!
Will! Will! Will!
*cris*
*musique dubstep*
Arrêtes !
Mais pourquoi tu fais ça?
Mais ça fait mal!
Arrêtes là putain!
Aïe! Mon doigt putain!
Kamehameha!
Expelliarmus!